[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro du ctu klepto 26 minutes pour
revenir sur l'actualité de la semaine
dans les yvelines
au sommaire ce vendredi 31 janvier lors
de son assemblée départementale mensuel
le département a annoncé une diminution
de son taux de taxe foncière
nous détaillerons cette information les
chiffres du chômage ont été publiées en
début de semaine et affiche une baisse
significative au niveau national dans
les yvelines on enregistre aussi une
baisse nous en discuterons avec notre
invité directeur de la gestion pôle
emploi de guyancourt des pompiers
solidaire avec l'australie un point sur
le chantier du 'pipeline' à autrui y ait
une soirée dédiée à l'orientation
professionnelle à montigny le bretonneux
nous reviendrons sur les événements qui
ont marqué la semaine dans votre
département
une dernière cérémonie de voeux pour
conclure ce mois de janvier le président
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines recevait
hier soir au vélodrome nationale élus
associatifs et encore partenaires
institutionnels pour évoquer les
perspectives 2020 il était question
d'éducation de sécurité avec la
concrétisation du projet de
commissariats d'arrondissement sur la
ville d'elancourt de mobilité avec des
modes de déplacement plus respectueux de
l'environnement
jean michel fourgous est également
revenu sur l'attractivité économique du
territoire
est-ce qu'on peut relever essentiel
c'est qu'en fait on réussit tout ça on
arrive à des moyens exceptionnels des
soutiens des partenaires assez
exceptionnel ça ça c'est important parce
que on a décidé de d'être un peu au delà
des partis et de travailler en confiance
avant
voilà avant autre chose et quand on voit
que ça marche ça renforce la confiance
et ça renforce le fait qu'on ait eu
raison
venez passer un peu les clivages on est
très heureux mais on est très heureux
parce qu'on travaille tous ensemble
c'est pas c'est pas l'un contre l'autre
c'est la confiance et parler vrai aussi
c'est inspire confiance parler vrai
quand vous racontez du baratin et quand
vous réussissez ben oui on voit bien que
les réussites et souvent elles sont
réelles il n'y a pas une année pas
parfait mais il ya une fuse moi j'ai
jamais vu un tel un thé l'éventail
d'innovation ce vendredi matin s'est
tenue l'assemblée départementale les
yvelines reste le département français
avec le plus faibles les plus faibles
dépenses de fonctionnement par habitant
avec 731 euros chacun lors de cette
séance le président a annoncé la
diminution de 8% de son taux de taxe
foncière sur les propriétés bâties en
2020 soit une baisse d'un point passant
à 11,58 % pierre bédier au micro de
manon varaldo d'autres fiscalité qui a b
c qui fait de notre département
non plus le septième département le
moins fiscalisés de france mais le
quatrième
donc nous avons bien progressé et on
retrouve la place qui était la nôtre
avant une augmentation à laquelle l'état
nous avait contraints
à 4 ans je rappelle que l'état nous
donnait 150 millions d'euros soit 15 %
de notre budget et qu' il a décidé de ne
plus nous donnait que 15 millions
d'euros c'est à dire dix fois moins et
qu'il nous avait donc enlevé presque 14
% du budget
[Musique]
en début de semaine pôle emploi publié
ses chiffres du chômage une baisse
record du nombre de demandeurs d'emploi
depuis la crise de 2008 avec un recul de
3 3% au niveau national dans les
yvelines la baisse vous le voyez aller 2
3 % 64100 chômeurs de catégorie a en
décembre 2019 soit 842 moins 840 de
moins qu'en 2018
des chiffres que nous allons commenter
avec vous josé manuel rodriguez bonjour
bonjour alors vous êtes directeur de
l'agencé pôle emploi de guyancourt une
baisse importante on l'a dit mais le
chiffre est moins fort dans les yvelines
qu'au niveau national comment on peut
expliquer ça c'est vrai que les chiffres
est indéniablement plus faible que celui
de l'île de france constitue tout de
même à 0,6 point en dessous de la
moyenne régionale avec effectivement des
départements qui ont des pistes très
élevé avec des volumétries importantes
de baisse dues des demandeurs d'emploi
et d'autres qui sont à peu près au même
niveau que les évident il faut rappeler
que derrière les chiffres 64 mille
demandeurs d'emploi c'est environ 9,8
pour cent du poids total des demandeurs
d'emploi sur l'ensemble de la région ile
de france
quand les départements pour lesquels la
baisse est la plus importante paris et
la seine saint denis représente 19 et 17
% respectivement
vous voyez on a un taux de chômage qui
est relativement faible en parallèle 6
6% pour vous abreuver de chiffres enfin
ça me donne nuit un éclairage et entre
ce taux de chômage qui est relativement
faible et la volumétrie des demandeurs
d'emploi qui pas faible mais qui est
quand même nettement inférieure à ce
qu'elle est par ailleurs on se rend
compte qu'on a affaire à une situation
où on commence à toucher un noyau dur de
chômage de personnes qui sont installés
dans du change de longue durée et des
freins périphériques qui sont des
éléments autour d'eux les difficultés de
logement de santé de mobilité parfois et
c'est vrai que pour nous conseiller il
ya et il ya un sujet autour de comment
travailler autrement avec ses publics
comment travailler avec en partenariat
avec d'autres acteurs
il faut aussi dire que c'est un
département les yvelines un département
historiquement dynamique avec des zones
d'emploi importantes nous sommes sur une
zone d'emploi 50 ans divine
particulièrement importante avec plus de
50000 emplois
c'est le cas aussi de vélizy sur une
partie du département la vallée de seine
qui est un département à une partie du
département avec un réservoir d'emplois
important et il faut signaler aussi que
les yvelines sont situés quand même au
carrefour de deux
d'autres zones d'emploi proche la
défense pour ne pas la citer qui est la
première zone quasiment d'emploi de
france et puis paris intra muros qui qui
quand même à quelques à quelques
kilomètres à peine de notre zone
donc tout ça concourt au fait que c'est
un département qui est déjà
historiquement avec un taux de chômage
et un volume de demandeurs d'emploi plus
faible qu'ailleurs
et c'est vrai que là on arrive à toucher
quelque chose de plus complexe c'est ce
qu'on appelle la polarisation du marché
de l'emploi un marché de l'emploi qui
fait que les personnes qui sont
extrêmement qualifiés retrouver un
emploi plus facilement les personnes qui
sont moins qualifiés retrouver un emploi
parce que la situation économique est
meilleure
peut-être parfois de moins grande durée
avec beaucoup d'allers-retours entre
chômage et retour à l'emploi et les
emplois intermédiaires eux sont ceux qui
aujourd'hui peuvent un peu souffrir de
la situation souffrir de manière
relative parce qu'encore une fois on est
sur un une situation qui est moins
importante que ce qu'elle a été par le
passé est moins important que ce qu'elle
est sur certains départements d'île de
france
vous l'avez déclarations c'est que c'est
le noyau dur finalement du chômage
longue durée qui a été touchée comment
on explique finalement cette baisse du
chômage elle et elle est liée au fait
qu' un certain nombre de mesures qui ont
été prises probablement sont aujourd'hui
payante
la baisse du coût de l'emploi les
mobilisations alors nous à pôle emploi
on accompagne ces éléments de
conjoncture avec une mobilisation accrue
autour de la facilitation des
entreprises sur le recrutement c'est
17,61 demandeurs 61 conseiller pardon
qui s'occupe aujourd'hui des questions
liées au recrutement sur l'ensemble du
département on a augmenté de 17
conseillers
cette capacité à traiter des besoins
d'entreprises et à réduire la durée de
ces recrutements difficiles on a un
élément autour d'eux un partenariat fort
avec le conseil départemental sur le
traitement justement des demandeurs
d'emploi les plus éloignés les
bénéficiaires du rsa et les minima
sociaux autour d'une convention qui est
maintenant devenu historique qui est là
depuis 2015 et qui est l'accompagnement
global juste rappeler que
l'accompagnement global en 2019 ce sont
près de 1600 demandeur d'emploi 1595
pour être précis qui ont été accompagnés
conjointement par des travailleurs
sociaux et des conseillers de pôle
emploi qu'il faut qu'il faut saluer sur
la qualité du travail rendu et qui a
provoqué sous 51% de retour à l'emploi
sur des publics qui sont
largement installée dans le chômage
deuxième élément c'est que il ya un plan
d'investissement sur les compétences qui
fait que concrètement en 2019
les services de pôle emploi se sont
mobilisés en lien avec certains autres
services et les conseils régionaux
notamment en ce qui concerne l'achat de
formation l'achat de formation pour
faire en sorte que des actions de
formation se mettent en place pour
permettre à nos demandeurs d'emploi
d'adapter leurs compétences aux besoins
des entreprises c'est 13007 13000
personnes qui ont bénéficié d'une action
de formation
et quand on regarde si les personnes au
terme de l'action de la formation sont
arrivés à retrouver un emploi
c'est presque 60% qui ont recouvré un
emploi au terme de ces formations les
formations autour de la logistique des
formations si de remise à niveau parce
que de plus en plus la remise à niveau
est nécessaire parce qu'on recrute de
moins en moins sur des diplômes que sur
d aptitude à pouvoir apprendre et des
aptitudes surtout à la relation sociale
la capacité à pouvoir être en interface
avec un public et donc c'est un c'est un
point important
vingt-quatre mille demandeurs d'emploi
en bénéficier de prestations de retour à
l'emploi
travailler avec eux sur comment un
entretien doit se dérouler comment on
travaille la recherche d'emploi comment
est-ce qu'on valorise sa as
justement ces candidatures comment est
ce qu'aujourd'hui on passe de métiers
recherchés qui était leur plat perdue à
quelque chose d'autre qui est plutôt
rechercher des emplois qui
réinvestissent des compétences qu'on
détient et cette approche compétences
elle est essentielle aussi à travailler
avec les entreprises et on s'est attaché
beaucoup pour l'emploi en 2019 à mettre
en place des événementiels ou labellise
hashtag vers un métier et qui permettent
à des entreprises de venir valoriser
leur métier auprès de demandeurs
d'emploi parfois en présence
d'organismes de formation et pour
l'emploi joue son rôle d'intermédiaire
et puis il ya aussi d'autres
partenariats qui sont mises en oeuvre
avec la fédération française du bâtiment
avec l'union des métiers de l'industrie
hôtelière et avec le club hôtelier des
yvelines en lien avec la chambre de
commerce et d'industrie qui vise
justement à faire connaître des métiers
qui aujourd'hui peut être eu plus de
difficultés à recruter
et c'est tout le travail de pôle emploi
que de permettre de trouver c'est ce
champ des possibles dans le dans les
recrutements des entreprises à la fois
chez les demandeurs d'emploi en ouvrant
le spectre des possibilités de projets
professionnels et à la fois du côté des
entreprises en diversifiant le mode de
contact avec les demandeurs d'emploi
mais aussi en faisant évoluer
peut-être un tant soit peu leur mode de
fonctionnement concernant le recrutement
le diplôme est peut être moins important
que la capacité d'adaptation des
personnes d'accompagnement de la
formation des partenariats avec des
entreprises
ce retour à l'emploi est ce qu'il est ce
tableau final ce que c'est des contrats
qui sont pas précaire mais durable il
est stable puisque concrètement quand
l'emploi n'est pas stable vous voyez pas
les chiffres de baisse
être aussi importants même s'ils sont
encore une fois relativement mais la
question c'est passé c'est pas un score
s'est passé pas une compétition puisque
ça mais ces deux emplois pérennes et ce
qui nous le démontre à nous c'est que
l'incrémentation des offres d'emploi de
10% se fait sur des cds sur des contrats
à durée indéterminée et sur des contrats
à durée déterminée long au détriment de
tout ce qui est contrat à durée
déterminée cours ou même des missions
intérimaires courte donc ce qui démontre
bien que le marché de l'emploi a
fortement évolué aussi l'attractivité
des offres d'emploi est devenu un vrai
sujet pour les employeurs aussi très
bien alors quels sont les secteurs qui
recrutent finalement dans les yvelines
alors je vous disais tout à l'heure à la
fois les secteurs qui sont extrêmement
demandeurs de compétences techniques on
a un volant dans d'entreprises
importantes autour de l'informatique
autour de l'ingénierie
sauf sur un territoire où il ya le
technocentre a été que ce technocentre
donne beaucoup de travail beaucoup de
prestataires de l'ingénierie il y a les
métiers classiques de la vente et du
commerce
on a des centres commerciaux sur les
yvelines en plusieurs et qui sont
pourvoyeurs d'emplois les métiers de
l'aide à la personne sont aussi des
métiers qui on le sait bien sont des
vrais leviers aujourd'hui et des virées
you read le retour à l'emploi
l'hôtellerie restauration constitue
encore et toujours un élément important
on est sur un département touristique
aussi pour partie et la 3e de transport
logistique parce que nous avons des
plates formes logistiques parce que nous
avons des entreprises du secteur
industriel qui ont aussi besoin de
travailler sur la gestion des stocks et
sur le transport
on arrive à la fin de cet entretien
merci josé manuel rodriguez d'être venu
sur d'autres plateaux on passe à
l'essentiel de l'actualité de la semaine
[Musique]
les différents représentants de l'union
européenne étaient dans les yvelines
jeudi à la veille de l'application du
bric site
ursula von der leyen david sassoli et
charles michel se sont réunis à la
maison jean monnet située à bazoches sur
guyonne lieu symbolique de la
construction de l'union
les trois présidents débattu de l'avenir
de l'union les défis géopolitiques
actuelles et les transitions climatique
et numérique
ils ont conduit une déclaration publique
comme largement commune largement
orientée sur le bric site ce vendredi
une action solidaire maintenant en
faveur de l'australie ravagé par les
incendies
dix personnes dans huit sapeurs pompiers
des yvelines vont aller sur place afin
de prêter main forte aux secours ils
partent du 6 au 21 février
leur mission est d' aux animaux dont
plus d'un milliard sont morts
reconstruction et accompagnement des
pompiers locaux
une démarche indépendante et financé en
partie grâce à une cagnotte en ligne
propos recueillis par mélanie poker on
sait pertinemment qu depuis à plusieurs
semaines ils sont à bout ils commencent
à être fatigués et ont juste leur
apporter un soutien on n'a pas la
prétention de venir révolutionner
australie mais on va apporter notre
petit soutien c'est nous qui avons
choisi de faire ça totalement
bénévolement
on a posé des congés on a financé noah
billets d'avion et c'est pour ça qu'on a
créé une petite cagnotte afin de
nous aider dans les différents frais sur
place et notamment pourquoi pas dans le
financement de différents matériels pour
les gens peu désoeuvrés
il est attendu chaque année dans le
monde de la restauration le guide
michelin a dévoilé lundi son palmarès
2020 pas de nouvelles étoiles pour les
chevignois mais une bonne nouvelle quand
même les sept restaurants une étoile
conservent leur distinction à savoir les
établissements versailles et du corps
d'un drame c'est de la table du 11 et
encore la table des boulots à temps
pierre est le numéro trois pour trembler
sur l'autre après l' incendie de l'arche
le chapiteau qui abritait la compagnie
des contraires à chanteloup les vignes
en novembre dernier l'association
continue ses actions il ne lui aura
fallu qu'une semaine pour se relever et
avancer un nouveau château devrait même
être installé mi mars faire ici
maintenant avec deux vis de la compagnie
des contraire créé en 1991 alors
naturellement lincendie de l'arche en
novembre dernier n'allait pas les
arrêter on va couler encore autour la
d'arles au jardin en train de préparer
et caetera et nous allons monter en
chapiteau en toile qui était acheté en
belgique qui doit arriver vers le mois
de mars
un chapiteau à 40000 euros financés
grâce à l'aide de la région ile de
france et son enveloppe de cent mille
euros
il viendra s'installer à côté du site
sinistré avec pour objectif de pouvoir
tenir le traditionnel festival annuel de
cirque du 3 au 5 avril à venir de la
culture a mené de la joie de l'unité de
la fraternité et de respect ça c'est le
futur
en attendant la compagnie des contraires
continue ses nombreux projets c'est une
maison bleue
et au plein coeur de la brouille est un
chantier d'insertion redonne des
couleurs à la place de l'échauguette
avec de la mosaïque un chantier mené par
une artiste qui travaille avec la
compagnie depuis 16 ans donc je
découvert cette vivre avec mais aux
atomes ghazi et je suis tombée amoureuse
immédiatement pour moi c'était un petit
bout du brésil toutes ces études mito
toutes ces femmes toutes ses enfants de
working piège on est tous assez
c'est fantastique depuis trois semaines
ses hommes ont appris l'art de la
mosaïque
un chantier qui rend la ville plus belle
leur apprend de nouvelles compétences et
leur permet de travailler comme mourad
qui enchaîne les missions pour la
compagnie depuis plusieurs années on est
obligé de continuer son contenu sont
s'arrêter baril avait gagné
malheureusement sans tuer d'insertion
break tout à fait avec tu te font sucer
pas eu la personne qui fait le saut
réussi pendant que les morceaux de
carreaux se dessine la compagnie des
contraires recherche déjà de nouveaux
projets et continue de ne regarder que
devant elle pour le futur du quartier de
la noé
direction maintenant août au tout y est
nous avons pris des nouvelles du
chantier du 'pipeline' ce dernier
s'était rompu il ya 11 mois provoquant
une fuite de 900 mille litres de pétrole
le morceau dommages et a été remplacé
depuis mars 2010 9 50 mille mètres cubes
de terres polluées ont été retirés des
contrôles de pollution sont toujours en
cours le protocole de total a été
envoyée à la préfecture pour recevoir
une validation de l'état fin du chantier
prévue pour octobre 2020 on écoute le
chef du projet de réhabilitation au
micro de nicolas landry et jacques brun
nous sommes donc en train de rapporter
de la terre minérale autour du bail
klein pour le protéger et dans une
deuxième phase on en rapportera de la
terre minérales et de la terre végétale
pour permettre aux agriculteurs de
reprendre leurs pratiques culturales
classique on creuse plus ou moins
profondément en fonction
de la qualité des sols que l'on prélève
et que l'on fait analyser dans des
laboratoires pour savoir si on a des
hydrocarbures ou plus d'hydrocarbures
collégiens lycéens et étudiants avait
rendez vous mercredi en fin de journée à
montigny le bretonneux pour leur
orientation
organisé par le pôle jeunesse de la
ville la manifestation avait plusieurs
objectifs informer mais aussi à rassurer
les plus stressés aurélien à réfléchir
sur son avenir professionnel à la lueur
des bougies
c'est le concept proposé depuis 2012 par
le service jeunesse de montigny le
bretonneux différents pôles
d'information ont permis aux élèves mais
aussi à leurs parents d'y voir plus
clair
c'est très compliqué en plus nous on a
quitté l'école ya déjà un moment donc on
connaît moins les écoles les filières
d'aujourd'hui dans l'informatique par
exemple beaucoup de nouveaux métiers
sont créés et quand on connaît pas donc
c'est pas évident pour nous de devoir
les aider les aiguilles souvent il ya
une part d'angoise autour de
l'orientation le fait d'être accompagné
par des professionnels ça
ça permet de dédramatiser un petit peu
et de prendre le temps
au programme conférences pour mieux
connaître les dates clés de
l'orientation stands de découverte des
métiers et de formations possibles sur
notre territoire les plus indécis
pouvait effectuer des tests
d'orientation en ligne
je me dis que si je sais pas trop quoi
faire assez vite bas
pour mes études sérieuses d'être
compliqué autre inquiétude pour les
élèves et notamment les terminales les
inscriptions depuis la semaine dernière
sur parcours sup la plateforme
d'admission postbac
il faut le redire c'est aujourd'hui vous
devez faire un choix qui est difficile
mais par rapport à qui vous êtes
maintenant peut-être ici 5 10 ans on ne
serait plus la même personne n'aurait
plus les mêmes objectifs et du coup vous
aurez le droit de changer concernant
parcours sup les élèves ont jusqu'au 12
mars pour saisir leurs voeux projection
projection spéciale mardi à jouy en
josas les habitants ont pu découvrir le
film je ne rêve que de vous dédié à
l'histoire d'amour entre léon blum et
jeanne reichenbach est sorti le 15
janvier dernier
un film qui rend également hommage à la
maison du couple devenu musée dans la
commune la projection était suivie d'un
débat avec l'équipe du film dont
l'actrice elsa zylberstein dans le rôle
de jeanne blum ravis de présenter
l'oeuvre dans sa ville natale
ça fait genre en 25 ans je suis pas
rentré dans cette salle des fêtes
donc ça m'émeut énormément c'est
l'endroit où je faisais mes gars là
dedans quand j'étais petit ça me fait
quelque chose de jouer une amoureuse
comme ça une famille répressive vivante
vibrante c'est toujours voilà c'est
toujours des rôles magique
ce week end a lieu la troisième édition
de sport féminin toujours opération
lancée par le csa et le ministère des
sports
différentes actions sont portés le
développement des pratiques afin de
corriger les inégalités d'accès ou
encore la lutte contre les
discriminations et les violences faites
aux femmes dans le champ du sport au
vélodrome nationale à montigny le
bretonneux des animations auront lieu le
samedi dès 14h opération 100% filles en
2019 la fédération française de cyclisme
n'a recensé que 12000 54 licenciés soit
environ 10% de ses effectifs
le ministère des sports qui a annoncé
vouloir légaliser la pratique des arts
martiaux mixtes en france
le mma pourtant longtemps décrié
interdit pour commenter cette
information mais quel ennemi d'euros a
reçu le premier vainqueur officiel d'un
combat de cette pratique est un gérant
de la salle au sein du 7-8 sport les
choix qu'a été donné c'est la boxe
anglaise s'était passé était donnée
gagnante du tout on est différents
sondages en fait à l'arrivée très très
très très loin
maintenant c'est un choix c'est un choix
et tant mieux parce qu'il fallait que ça
soit ça soit monde est délibérée il
fallait il fallait légiférer sur ça la
boxe anglaise s'est donné une fédé qui
marche depuis très longtemps qui a
habitué à organiser des galas prom point
professionnels un peu partout dans le
monde
si réellement ils les moyens sont mis
derrière pour développer le mma et et
tous qui toute la partie éducative parce
que le combat c'est bien mais c'est
toute la partie éducative c'est comment
comment cadrer les enfants correctement
dans les salles c'est si les moyens sont
mis par la fédé pour ça c'est génial
dans tous les cas c'est un grand pas
pour le mma temps quelques semaines le
salon de l'agriculture ouvrira ses
portes comme chaque année le département
des idées et fera bonne figure
l'occasion pour notre break ça s'est
passé de revenir sur l'édition 2019
[Musique]
au salon de l'agriculture 2010 9
dégustation de produits du terroir
français
découvertes gustatives visite
incontournable des animaux et petit
bisou pour certains je compte devenir
agriculteur dans quelques mois
et ça me semblait intéressant une c'est
une opportunité pour moi de venir de
voir un peu autre chose
et parmi tous les stands du salon
bientôt du vin 100% yvelinois en 2017 la
winery parisienne a planté ses premiers
pieds de vigne à d'avron elle veut
réinventer la filière viticole en ile-de
france vivait pour nous était de
reproduire des vins dans la plus grande
l'ancien plus grandes régions viticoles
de france et l'île de france
pour produire des grands vins dans la
région sur la place verte ailleurs la
première cuvée est annoncée pour 2020
côté assiette la ferme d alu et propose
des légumes anciens et nouveaux
sur les étalages topinambours radis noir
ou route à bagua j'ai une cinquantaine
d'hectares
fruits et légumes que je revends sur les
marchés en
de france 40 rouge suboxone rouge
novembre a demandé légumes qui sortent
de l'ordinaire
le département des yvelines est le
deuxième territoire agricole d'île de
france
il participe au salon pour la deuxième
fois avec les hauts-de-seine et ils sont
complémentaires parce que l'agriculture
c'est une production et une consommation
et si les yvelines sont un département
producteur se coller hauts-de-seine ne
sont pas les hauts-de-seine comme les
yvelines d'ailleurs sont des
départements consommateurs et en
particulier consommateurs dans nos
cantines scolaires de nos collèges les
yvelines favorisent les produits locaux
et intègre les produits issus de
l'agriculture biologique au concours
général agricole
y a eu la médaille d'argent sur un
yaourt à l'abricot destinés à la
restauration collective pour les enfants
des écoles du département audio
[Musique]
oh
on doit envoyer vous fait trente à
quarante mille fois par mois qui sont
dédiés
cantine au plus tôt le territoire des
yvelines est composé de 90 mille
hectares d'espacés agricoles
avec près de 1000 exploitations
l'agriculture c'est un marqueur fort des
yvelines aider à l'installation et au
renouvellement des générations
il faut installer des jeunes
agriculteurs des jeunes agricultrices et
donc on y travaille en les aidant
financièrement on les aide aussi à se
transformer au niveau écologique
énergétique vous pouvez encore faire un
tour le salon de l'agriculture se
termine ce dimanche 3 mars
[Musique]
autre rubrique celle de l'actualité or
yvelines
[Musique]
à l'heure de l'exemple du zéro déchet
les poubelles d'île de france n'ont
jamais été aussi plein les explications
par nos confrères biac emparé en
ile-de-france les poubelles débordent 7
millions de tonnes d'ordures ont été
jetés en 2018
un chiffre en augmentation ces cinq cent
mille de plus qu'en 2010 est tué cette
tendance concerne les déchets ménagers
professionnels alors pourquoi l'île de
france et à une mauvaise élève
la première explication vient d'un autre
continent la chine
n'importe plus nos déchets plastiques la
production déchets par habitant est
plutôt stable depuis quelques années et
bien mécaniquement comme on est plus
nombreux et bien le tonnage augmente ont
donc aussi celui qui est reçue sur les
incinérateurs
on a d'autres objectifs au niveau de la
valorisation énergétique et non plus la
valorisation matière et sa part contre
cet objectif est atteint en ile de
france
l'objectif de 2025 est déjà atteint dès
2018 autre raison elle est démographique
la loi de transition énergétique prévoit
une réduction de ses déchets en
ile-de-france de 30% cette année et de
moitié en 2025 si les objectifs semblent
ambitieux les espoirs se portent sur la
valorisation conseil régional dans son
plan déchets un site et c'est de mettre
en place avec les collectivités des
objectifs ambitieux pour réduire les f1
pour augmenter pardon la part des
déchets qui sont recyclés
on a d'autres objectifs au niveau de la
valorisation énergétique et non plus la
valorisation matière et sa part contre
cet objectif est atteint en ile de
france
l'objectif de 2025 est déjà atteint dès
2018 pour tenir les délais en ile de
france il faudrait réduire la capacité
totale des décharges à 1 million 400
mille tonnes en 2025
[Musique]
c'est la fin de cette édition merci de
nous avoir suivi on se quitte avec un
extrait du spectacle de caroline
vigneaux elle sera sur la scène du
théâtre alexandre dumas à saint germain
en laye le jeudi 6 février pour week-end
sur tv 78 nous c'est dix ans plus tard
1944 et attend à falloir attendre encore
pour avoir le droit de l'exercer 1945
ma grand mère a obtenu le droit de voter
bon elle a jamais voté mon grand père
voulait pas
[Musique]